public sénat et le centre national du
livre présente livres et vous
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans livres et vous
votre nouvelle émission littéraire qui
par des livres pour aller vers vous
chaque semaine je vous retrouve dans ce
lieu magnifique halle annexe de la
bibliothèque du sénat pour donner la
parole à ceux qui font vivre la
littérature ce qu'il écrit bien sûr mais
aussi ceux qui la lisent ou ceux qui
s'en inspirent qui sont inspire pour
agir et créer dans des domaines parfois
inattendus mon invité aujourd'hui vous
le connaissez très bien
ou plutôt vous pensez le connaître vous
le savez hommes politiques
il a été président de la république
française de 2007 à 2012
vous l'avez découvert récemment grand
connaisseur de football c'était sur
equipe tv et ce soir il va apparaître
comme le passionné de littérature qu'il
est bonjour nicolas sarkozy bonjour
merci de m'inviter
bienvenue sur livret vous c'est un grand
honneur vous connaissez ce lieu je
connais ce lieu
bon je n'ai jamais été sénateur je crois
que c'est d'ailleurs le seul bon dax
n'ai jamais exercé dans ma vie d'abord
parce que j'ai été longtemps trop jeune
pour pouvoir devenir sénateur fait les
35 ans à mon époque mais je connais ce
lieu pour être venu souvent dans les
réunions politiques ici au sénat parce
que le président n'a pas toujours le
bienvenu au sénat non mais j'ai pas été
coprésident chez des ministres et puis
j'ai des chefs de parti ce qui m'a
permis de venir souvent ici de vous
nicolas sarkozy on sait certaines choses
on ne s'est certainement pas tous mais
votre connaissance de la littérature
n'est pas la première chose que l'on
cite à votre sujet et pourtant je sais
car nous avons préparé cet entretien
qu'elle est immense non lui pose du tout
jugé trou épouvantable vous savez le
ceux qui me connaissent ceux qui sont
mes proches sauf que je ne pus très
longtemps je ne me déplace jamais sans
avoir un livre que je ne passe pas une
journée sans lire et c'est tellement
important pour moi peut-être à tort je
n'ai jamais voulu en parler je trouve
qu'il ya une forme de prétention de
cuistrerie à vouloir faire semblant que
nous manquait les livres que vous amenez
en vacances en général pour citer un
titre
que personne ne connaît et un livre
comme lira pas et donc c'était en
quelque sorte un jardin secret je n'en
ai jamais parlé
mais quand vous m'avez proposer cette
émission sur une grande chaîne nationale
dans ce lieu magique l'emport c'était
difficile de résister et maintenant
qu'il ya plus d'enjeu tucano jeu
politique
c'est beaucoup plus simple pour moi de
parler des choses sérieuses et la
littérature
c'est une chose très sérieuse parce que
c'était en contradiction avec l'exercice
politique pandore je dis pas que j'avais
raison mais ça me paraissait tellement
artificielle d'aller parler de choses
tellement intime parce qu'au fond ce que
vous aimez ce que vous lisez la façon
dont vous l'interprétez 110 tellement
sur vous et peut-être que durant toute
ma carrière politique j'ai pas voulu
dire tellement sur moi pas moi le
l'homme politique ou président d'un
public mais moins la personne non mais
on connaît c'est votre famille on aurait
pu connaître votre famille littéraire
par exemple
oui on m'a beaucoup reproché d'ailleurs
de connaître ma famille on ne va pas
reprocher de connaître mes mégots
littéraire peut être était ce une
occasion manquée en tout cas elle sera
rattrapé ce soir c'est un grand plaisir
pour moi de parler avec beaucoup de
subjectivité parce qu'il n'ya pas
d'objectivité en littérature est pour
moi le livre est tellement important que
c'est un concept en soi
à la question qu'on peut souvent quel
livre améliorée vous sur une île déserte
mais une bibliothèque par livre
faut-il ne pas aimer livre pour dire ça
c'est mon livre de chevet y en a qu'un
mon dieu quelle pauvreté ressent que
votre bibliothèque
c'est très simple c'est très organisé un
peu comme je suis pardon sur la partie
droite
enfin ça dépend droite et gauche ça veut
dire le point on part il ya tous les
livres que j'ai lus et sur l'autre
partie en face et à tout ce qui me reste
à lire et fort heureusement ce qui me
reste à l'air est infiniment plus
important que ce que j'ai déjà lus
n'est-ce pas classés par ordre
alphabétique
absolument pas c'est classé par
littérature étrangère ou littérature
française s'est classée par contemporain
ou
non contemporain j'aime pas le cas en
plastique qui ne veut absolument rien
dire
et puis de l'autre côté c'est le
fouillis de tout ce que je reçois que je
trie par exemple on m'a offert il ya six
mois
alfred de vigny le premier roman
historique c'est lui qui l'a fait au
début du 19e siècle choletais est gelée
commencé il ya trois semaines
arrivé à savoir ce qui vous donne envie
de lire un livre un moment c'est pas si
l'internaute vers 6 et l'alternance
aussi jeu j'aime bien le ternes et les
les romans du xixème et les romans
contemporains mais définitivement
j'aime leur nom c'est un choix définitif
est pour moi la littérature c'est
vraiment l'entrée dans dix neuvième
siècle avec le roman et j'aime ne vous
savez lévi-strauss ce que j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer à l'extrême fans
claude lévi-strauss anthropologue l'un
des hommes les plus brillants du xxème
siècle incontestablement écrit tristes
tropiques mais tristes tropiques
je l'interrogé je suis dit mais mais
mais tristes tropiques on a l'impression
de commencer par un roman et c'est un
essai et il m'a dit mais vous savez j'ai
voulu faire un roman et je ne suis pas
capable de faire un roman c'est à dire
de suivre un personnage de le décrire il
l'a mené jusqu'au bout pour moi
l'écrivain c'est d'abord le romancier
les romans mais surtout les romans du
xixème siècle
vous avez une fascination pour le 19e
siècle bon d'abord c'est difficile
d'évacuer la question du 19e siècle qui
est qui qui est l'arrivée du dur manchu
l'eau le roman et les nouvelles
aujourd'hui on regarde tellement de
série souvent j'ai pensé que les séries
d'aujourd'hui c'était les nouvelles
d'hier et le 19e siècle c'est quand même
le ciel de tous les génies en super
dumas jules verne maupassant
flaubert balzac tous victor hugo barbey
d'aurevilly enfin on peut multiplier
jusqu'à l'infini et je dois dire que
j'ai souvent pensé qu'on lisait serment
trop jeune compass est aujourd'hui ouais
je pense que l'éducation sentimentale il
faut être éduqués sentimentalement si on
peut l'être pour le lire je pense que le
père goriot on doit pas de mettre à 15
ans je pense que cdd vous qui est un
philosophe
ce sont des livres d'une philosophie
profonde qui ont ausculté la semaine au
plus profond et je dois dire que cette
racine et en même temps si on peut
initier les jeunes personnes à cette
lecture là parce que s'il faut attendre
d'avoir une certaine maturité
sentimentale pour lire parfois on ne
vous ne lirez jamais en des honda
millions les vous voyez je pense que ces
livres pas la même chose de l'irak 1-0
pas sans écueils au balzac par exemple
quelle différence entre les deux or ces
deux génies absolue mais les nouvelles
de maupassant c'est beaucoup plus facile
j'ai souvent pensé d'ailleurs qu'il
avait été influencé par cette normandie
avec ce climat parfois un peu plus vieux
ces marécages et que ça devait bombe la
maison tellier
c'est drôle c'est pour de suif et cetera
c'est la petite rock on peut multiplier
leurs là et c'est me semble-t-il c'est
plus accessible ne laissant que l'oeuvre
de balzac qui est pour moi le premier
des féministes et dont l'essentiel des
personnages importants sur des femmes
le premier des féministes ils vont mais
comment balzac qui a été si malheureux
dans son mariage avec madame pense qu'à
quand même octave mirbeau le le raconte
dans la mort d'un soleil je crois que
c'est ça le titre madame brand ce cas
est tombée amoureuse de balzac était une
star en lui lisant ils sont écrits je
crois qu'ils sont rencontrés la première
fois à genève
et mais comment vous reconnaîtrai jeudi
dit j'aurais un exemplaire de mon livre
sous le bras il pleuvait et son manque
et c'est à elle attendue que le mari de
madame aux cartes mères ils sont mariés
ils sont venus de moscou elle était une
chrétienne je crois et la première
soirée a été épouvantable puisque balzac
avait dit à sa mère de préparer un
souper fin de prévoir un server le
serveur est devenu fou n'ont pas pu
rentrer dans la maison tout été saccagés
il était malheureux en amour
et pourtant comment il a parlé des
femmes à milan par la brillamment mais
ces femmes sont presque toutes
malheureuse en amour aussi mais elles
sont tellement fortes les hommes
mobilisables
or comment vous pensez à qui par exemple
comme mais enfin et écouter dans le curé
le curé de campagne
véronique qui est mal mariée qui est une
femme parfaite et puis qu'il fait un
enfant avec un jeune ouvrier qui va être
poussée je ne vais pas tout raconter
mais qui va être poussée ou crime
véronique qui va après se mortifier est
essayé de trouver la renaissance dans la
religion c'est un personnage
extraordinaire le cami mutins dans
beatrix c'est un personnage
extraordinaire elle reste fidèle
jusqu'au bout il va même pousser dans
les bras du petit jeune à calix sa
rivale et amie beau père je crois que
c'est son nom décrit exactement se
féliciter des touches c'est oui mais son
nom d'écrivain
camille ma part je pense qu'il a dû être
influencé votre part george george sand
quelque chose comme ça si vous regardez
tous les personnages au génie gandais et
elle n'est pas extraordinaire cette
gigandet balle tombe amoureux du cousin
qui est un petit fat
wingles oui c'est son cousin pays elles
sont amoureuses je crois qu'il s'appelle
charles il est le fils du frère de son
père ton ancien sas ans et son cousin
elle l'attend et lui donne tout il n'a
trahi
elle va régler les dettes pour lui
permettre de se marier c'est elle le
personnage central mais elle meurt
d'amour pour vous c'est une faiblesse
souci majeur mais ça fait de lui un
écrivain féministe on aurait attendu des
fans justement quid du cas s'ils gagnent
leurs combats salle et un nom saf
d'abord disons les choses un quelconque
en gagne nos vies dures une seconde et
on est certain de mourir donc voir si le
destin de l'homme c'est de gagner
on va alors ça veut dire que d'aucun
d'entre nous ne gagne puisque on
terminera tous avec le rendez vous avec
la mort mais il a parlé de l'amour comme
d'un absolu et montre que les femmes ont
un absolu que la femme mal mariée n'est
pas une traînée n'est pas une courtisane
canal draw bonheur elle aussi est que
bien souvent les hommes sont décevants
par rapport aux femmes dans la quête
d'absolu
c'est d'une modernité extrême et moi ça
me touche
balzac parlant des femmes seront c'est
extraordinaire mais pourrait parler de
la femme de 30 ans on pourrait parler du
lys dans la vallée les femmes savaient
mais elle peut être adepte pourriez vous
dire elle aime trop mais ce qu'on aime
trop dans la vie ce qui est important
c'est d'aimer qu'elle etc et quel sens
de la vie qui est qui qu'est ce qui
reste dans tout ça quand vous retournez
vous êtes très jeune mais quand je
tenais un peu moins jeune et qu'on se
retourne sur ce qu'on a fait qu'est ce
qui est plus important
on a aimé on dit pas le mystère de la
vie ne peut être transcendé que parler
essayer de partager et on partage par
l'amour et c'est tout tout club de balsa
en tout cas je suis pas mal assyriens je
suis pas un lettré sub un spécialiste
mais moi quand je lis je lis comme ça et
je dis à ceux qui qui vont pas lu ses
livres mais lisez l'essai d'une
modernité extraordinaire je parlais avec
un jeune écrivain français
le retour de jeunes le retour des beaux
jours voire en heures de pointe est un
très beau roman et nous parlions
béatrice et il me disait j'espère qu'il
ne m'en voudra pas de trahir cette
anecdote qu'il a lu béatrix et qu'il a
été tellement stupéfait de la capacité
de balzac à décrire guirande parce que
ça se passe en bretagne qui l'a dit
j'arrête de lire ce livre parce que moi
même je je suis de là bas ma femme est
de là-bas et ça pouvait me paralyser ses
d'une modernité d'une force tajine y
absolue mais vous dites lavaud ne vit
d'être vécue que si on vit un tel amour
absolu votre vie a connu d'autres choses
que l'amour a certes connu l'amour qui
suce pour en juger
mais vous avez été président de la
république vous avez exercé des postes
très importants vous avez été conduits
par d'autres choses que l'amour oui mais
c'est toujours la même histoire
au fond c'est l'histoire du partage vous
pouvez appeler ça amour mais c'est le
partage qui tombe qui est en cause donc
politique ou amour peu importe le but
c'est de partager ce volume et la cdm et
c'est d'aimer et des romans d'amour qui
est d'ailleurs
et d'ailleurs on porte pas forcément
d'amour et d'ailleurs quand vous lisez
je suis de ceux qui pensent que le livre
appartient tout autant celui qui le lit
qu'à celui qui l'écrit que vous pouvez
aimer un livre et ne pas aimer son
auteur que le livre est différent de
l'auteur et que le chacun d'entre nous
qui lit un livre une interprète à sa
manière et on est propriétaire à sa
manière
alors vous dites le livre est différent
l'appel du partage vous à fermer le
livre est différent de l'auteur si on
l'appliqué au contexte contemporain qui
est celui en face il ya quelques
semaines de la décision de publier ou
non les textes antisémites de céline
céline est connue et reconnue comme
étant l' écrivain génial du voyage au
bout de la nuit que vous avez lu je
crois d'autres oeuvres qui sont même
plusieurs fois c'est ce même si vous
pensez vous du fait des peut-on
distinguer l'homme de l'oeuvre et donc
du coup ne pas publiquement produits les
le tard mais d'abord pardon c'est une
idée très banal que
l'oeuvre et le moment sublime de
l'auteur donc un auteur n'est pas
sublime toute sa vie dans sa case as des
instants l'oeuvre c'est ce moment de
grâce où l'inspiration qui vient de
jeunes 6 ou produit un génie
céline haïti antisémite mais briller
miss céline sans être antisémite pendu
céline a fait trois chefs-d'oeuvre le
voyage au bout de la nuit qui n'est pas
son premier livre je crois que s'il doit
être 28 aucun comme ça puisque premier
vrai ouvrage de céline c'est sa thèse de
médecine mort à crédit que vous avez lu
la thèse de m vêtements puisqu'elle a
été publiée il ya une quinzaine d'années
chez gallimard
quelle idée qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans
sa thèse de médecine c'est très
intéressant pour comprendre l'oeuvre de
céline parce que c'est une thèse qu'il
réalise sur un jeune médecin hongrois du
début du 19e siècle qui s'appelle samuel
vice et c'est très important parce que
ça me va ça consacré toute sa vie à
essayer de comprendre pourquoi les
femmes accouchent et par des étudiants
en médecine
moore est davantage en couches que celle
qui était à coucher par des sages femmes
seraient dues être le contraire et ça me
va découvre que parce la mortalité
supérieure avec les étudiants en
médecine était due au fait que après les
dissections il ne l'avait pas les mains
c'est la sepsie et on voit l'obsession
initiale de céline sur le microbe qui
devient dans la folie antisémite mort à
crédit qui sont sa biographie et d'un
château l'autre qui est exceptionnel la
mâche 26 de marine guen etc
il a fait ces trois chefs-d'oeuvre
mais on peut être bouleversée par le
voyage qui est un livre unique
absolument exceptionnel avec des moments
de génie quand il arrive aux états unis
et qui est décrit dit tu sais tu cei
ici les villes sont debout chez nous
elles sont couchés dans trois mots il
vous explique états unis quand
son capitaine dans les tranchées la saur
et se fait décapiter par un une balle
est il écrit tu sais l'imbécile il n'y
aurait donc que le courage n'est qu'un
manque d'imagination
bon le record les lits elle savait mais
lily savez et aimez et dit l'amour c'est
infini mise à la portée des caniches
bon qu'est ce que vous voulez je vous
dise céline n'est pas réductible à son
antisémitisme
malade il a fait des des bouquins très
ennuyeux il a fait des bouquins très
scandaleux mais ça n'enlève rien au
génie du voyage n'ont même pas les
publier parce que c'est une forme de
peut-être de censure ça ne pas les
publier
moi je crois que ça ne valait pas la
peine de les publier parce que lippok
avec les réseaux sociaux est une époque
ya si peu de repères pourquoi étudier
travailler des textes qui sont à ce
point scandaleux un moment où le racisme
et l'antisémitisme sont extrêmement
prégnant je vois pas ce que ça mais
parce qu'il faut savoir nommer l'ennemi
pour mieux pouvoir le combattre quelle
est la marolle pour mieux retard d'abord
les en me limitant le cube d'abord
l'ennemi s'est passé linky et menant
leur dynamique de l'indicé mythe
gémeauxun est exactement 1961 au début
des années 60
depuis en termes d' antisémitisme il ya
eu pire
et qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va on va
dire ça c'est un menkouande earth a déjà
été publié au canada
et puis vous savez avec tout ce
négationnisme on met des textes c'est
une d'une certaine façon c'est les
canonisé que d'en discuter mais l'heure
tourne et le dolley les fait pas
disparaître
on ne tourne pas le dos céline est un
grand écrivain
pour ces trois livres et pour le reste
c'est une honte je préférerais qu'on
publie la correspondance de céline qui
est d'abord très drôle que vous avez
légalement non j'ai pas tous les atouts
les mais vous savez ces lignes étaient
en prison de mende céline a été sauvé
par les danois peuple remarquable
parce que céline aurait été la
libération je suis pas sûr qu'il y
passait pas et qu'en prison et jean paul
sartre que j'admire pas énormément même
si j'ai aimé les mots son autobiographie
accueil extraordinaire j'adore les deux
parties souvenez tenir écrire mais il ya
une correspondance de de céline qui
faisait passer par son avocat assez
assez sévère à l'endroit de jps tu es
bien petit jps à l'endroit de mon anus
où tu te trouves c'est pas moi avec
tu te trouves à l'instant que j'écris
c'est beau donc la correspondance peut
expliquer un contexte mais espèce de
torchon antisémite je ne vois pas ce que
ça va amener franchement je ne vois pas
ce que ça mais que les historiens le
travail que les agrégés de travail c'est
une chose mais qu'on en fasse une
publication fût ce avec une préface
critique que personne ne lira et où des
gens pas former un peu déglingué et qui
avait pas besoin de ça vont se repaître
d'une folie antisémite qu'est-ce que ça
mais c'était contre la publication de
mein kampf également mais manquerait
plus que ça je ne sais pas si vous avez
lu ce livre
excusez moi si j'ai corse sn bergère une
histoire allemande
c'est fascinant on voit ce vulgaires
imbéciles d'hitler fascinant ce que
l'armée prussienne avait deux nobles
dans un repas qui dure cinq heures mais
analyser le torchon qui a dans mein
kampf je vois pas l'intérêt on a déjà
assez de problèmes il ya déjà sept
singles et là parce que les problèmes
viennent de là aussi là pour le coup ce
sera ta part des qualités littéraires ce
serait pour les problèmes ne viennent
pas de là les problèmes deviennent olav
du manque d'études de mein kampf ou des
propos antisémites de tel ou tel
les problèmes viennent d'une absence de
repères et d'une société occidentale qui
se sent un peu en décadence en décadence
pourquoi il ya sept milliards
d'individus sur la planète si vous
additionnez l'europe et des états unis
ça fait 800 millions
et donc cette société se sent que l' axe
du monde a migré de l'occident vers
l'orient c'est à dire vers l'asie
surtout au 19ème siècle on était parti
de là et on n'a pas en faux contre est
encore un petit peu
vous plaisantez lorsque vous dites quoi
faire la semaine vous avez vous avez
présenté balsa comme cet écrivain
féministe que vous que vous aimez qui
propose des personnages de femmes qui
croit en l'amour absolu
on retrouve cette croyance en un amour
alors pas forcément absolue et qui se
solde aussi par un échec
j'ai deux autres auteurs 19e siècle
stendhal d'un côté et flaubert de
l'autre alors comme vous avez une
lecture à contre-courant de balzac
j'imagine que c'est la même chose de de
stendhal si on prend la chartreuse de
parme par exemple dans la chartreuse de
parme il ya le personnage principal tel
qu'il est en tout cas le celui que le
narrateur mai au centre fabrice qui n'a
aucun de cet abri del dongo
il n'a aucun intérêt pour eux il a aucun
intérêt dans ce cas aux anti héros c'est
ça qu'il a menti tout ce pauvre fabrice
une personnalité très fan très très très
très falote il est bellâtre il était si
vous souvenez est exact sa tante la zone
tibhirine alem énormément lui ne se rend
pas compte y croise waterloo le waterloo
de fabrice souvenez-vous de cette scène
un peu gros comme ça raconte l histoire
il se retrouve justement sur l'âge se
retrouve son waterloo quand tout est
fini il tombe heiva nui je ne me
souviens plus j'ai pas lu plus longtemps
mais enfin je connais l'histoire ramené
par une aubergiste à la poitrine
abondante qui le met dans sa dans son
chariot et voila voila quoi interdit il
faut avouer que notre héros était fort
peu héros en ce moment oui donc tu en as
pas bon après simplement nishar il est
mis en prison il tombe amoureux de la
fille du colonel elia conti ou audubon
qui garde
enfin bref une personne sans aucun
intérêt non le pour moi le héros
magnifique de la chartreuse parmi ces
mots ce cas précis et moi ce cas premier
ministre de la république de parme et
mosca lui c'est un homme qui sait y met
et pascal qui va épouser sa tente
justement la dre
kif fou d'elle ouais et qui lui sacrifie
tout y compris sur l'ambition mais là on
est posée au cul quand même dans les
angles armes et vous vous préférez un
cocu à un antihéros d'abord soyons tous
extrêmement modèle en matière d'amour
des mésaventures pour arriver à chacun
certes ben donc ça doit amener grande
modestie mais ce qui m'intéressait pas
on n'est jamais ridicule c'est la
manière dont on prend les choses qui
peut rendre ridicule mosquée tromper
mais il est extrêmement digne ils
l'aiment
quand on aime on est à la fois
extrêmement faibles x à montfort
souvenez-vous de céline l'amour c'est
infini mise à la portée des caniches
gallimard vient de publier les lettres
admirable ni à 1200 pages que je n'ai
pas lu d'ailleurs les lettres d'amour
entre maria casarès et a dit c'est
albert camus génie absolu
il est dans les années 50 3 56 57 y
reçoit le prix nobel de littérature il
écrit une petite carte albert camus il
dessine un petit soleil comme s'il avait
4 ans d'âge mental il écrit à son
amoureuse maria-casarès au milieu de
toutes ces glaces un seul soleil toi
l'amour cet infini mise à la portée des
caniches qui que nous soyons et mosquée
n'est pas ridicule parce qu'il est
trempé qui par gulli des ding il va tout
lui donner
il aime cette femme sur fabrice not
amoureux que de lui alors on peut
choisir entre le conte moskau fabrice
del dongo figurez-vous que françoise
sagan avait une troisième hypothèse
qu'elle défend je vous propose qu'on
l'ait coûte tout de suite françoise
sagan qui vous parle de stendhal qui
vous propose sa lecture de la chartreuse
de parme
une aussi une chose assez étonnante
c'est chez stendhal je trouve en dehors
de ce charme extraordinaire cas pour moi
ce temps de galop qu'il a tout le temps
c'est qu'il était lui-même assez épais
courte au rouge et que tous ces jeunes
gens qui l'imaginé sont tous ce fringant
mince bon cavalier bon danseur plein de
charme et en général à mon avis un peu
niais à part le chat level qui plein de
charme pour moi
j'ai bien sûr elle est un peu pus rita
est un peu gênant comme personnage et
fabrice del dongo lebon fabrice est un
peu le cowboy si on peut dire d'une
littérature de stendhal fabrice passé
son temps à courir une amourette à
l'autre à cheval nous comprenons rien
s'attendre qu'il est le personnage
merveilleux de stendhal et finissant par
s'amouracher de clélia conti qu'il avait
strictement aucun intérêt sauf d'être vu
par une fenêtre à 10 m de ne pas pouvoir
la note plane donc à au début et les
femmes chez stendhal sont à mon sens
très intéressante parce que ce sont les
premières femmes de la littérature
française qui ne soit pas aux règlements
ennuyeux déroulement conventionnel
françoise sagan aussi à lecture
féministe de ces écrivains pour elle le
personnage principal de la chartreuse de
parme c'est plutôt la scène severina si
on est nommé d'abord françoise sagan
sais c'est le génie génie tous et
notamment des titres c'est vrai bonjour
tristesse
un chagrin de passage enfin bref il y
aurait tellement à dire sur france 5
je me permets de dire que je me
reconnais totalement dans ce qu'elle dit
de lucien lowen qui est pour moi le plus
grand des romans de stendhal la
description de lui l'ennui à nancy quand
lucien sur un cheval va sous les
fenêtres de madame chantecler ce conte
chant clair et qui tombe d'ailleurs
c'est absolument admirable le le roman
est inachevée mais il n'est pas une
hache et dans son histoire parce qu'on
voit le le lucien de vaines militaire on
voi lucien leven
politique il manquerait luche à levens
l'ecclésiaste où les y est bon quand
abriel donc mais je crois même que
flaubert a dit madame bovary c'est moi
ouais mais la manière dont ils savent
tous parler des femmes il ya cette
tradition regardez albert cohen belle du
seigneur
ariane comment albert cohen ce vieux
monsieur 68 sous le bord du lac léman et
fait 20 pages décrivant ariane dans sa
salle de bains dans son bain elle met un
pied en dehors de la baignoire puis elle
revient parce qu'elle attend cela comme
ça on a la garde derrière sont les
preneurs comment se glisse t-il dans la
peau des femmes pour faire des ddd 0in
comme cela s'est il trop ordinaire de
qui pourriez vous dire ce personnage
c'est moi non non moi je ne permettrai
pas de manger dit pas mais c'est vrai
que parfois quand je lis j'entendais des
gens qui savent tout de la littérature
et sert tellement de choses qui nous
retiennent rien
je crois que la littérature doit
l'incarner moi que je dis quand je lis
madame bovary jupe plusieurs fois alors
revenons-en à madame mais j'ai du mal à
trouver
sharon insignifiant encore une fois vous
prenez le contre-pied des lectures
charles est celui qui dès le début est
défini comme étant un homme nous comme
sa casquette une page sublime sur la
casquette de charles bovary qui est
décrite vous dire un bonnet à poil
m'echappe ce cas du chapeau rond de la
casquette de loutres du bonnet de coton
une de ces pauvres chose enfin dont la
laideur muette à des profondeurs
d'expression comme le visage d'un
imbécile
adèle vous juger quelqu'un sur son
bonheur sur son chapeau pour moi les
moules grotesque c'est rodolphe l'amant
c'est léon les amants de madame bovary
ils vont au bout de rien qu'ils sont
incapables de données qui sont
incapables de s'engager mais je pense
que dans anna karénine le héros c'est
c'est pas bros qui si monsieur carradine
quand elle va mourir souvenez-vous ses
occupants anna karénine qui est marié à
monsieur effectivement karénine et qui
apparemment ronces qui vous dit que le
héros encore une fois c'est le mari cocu
nom me faut vous avez pu repasser pour
lui nadal et de cannes c'est vrai nom
mais ce qu'ils n'ont que vous
privilégiez l'amour absolu
non je privilégie la guerre les lignes
c'est ça moi je suis quelqu'un qui aime
l'engagement pas je parle pas du tout
simplement l'engagement breux
l'engagement politique engagement
syndical l'engagement dans sa profession
j'aime les gens qui s'engagent
je n'aime pas la période un peu
d'aujourd'hui ont des angoisses installé
cinq ans pour voir si ça marche comme si
au bout de cinq ans ça marchait mieux
bon et pour souvenez de 2,2 de monsieur
carradine qui fait venir l'amant de sa
femme pour qu'elle s'inquiète s'en
sortent et et charles bovary sa femme
meurt puisqu'elle se suicide
si mon souvenir est exact et quelques
mois après l'enterrement il découvre les
lettres il lui appartenait il en veut
pas et il est même énervée par sa fille
charles bovary parce que la petite
oublie sa mère et lui il oublie pas oui
mais
sa mère n'avait pas sa fille parce
qu'elle l'a trouvée laide nous
d'inhalateurs difficile à l'otan quand
ils ne peuvent pas nasa propose que emma
et saute et my bell et crois que ça fait
la vie et maïs sont là surtout envie
d'aimer de rêver non
emma est prêt à tomber dans tous les
panneaux emma quand elle un chagrin
d'amour qu'est ce qu'elle fait je crois
que c'est monsieur l'heureux le
commerçant a acquis auprès de lui mais
je crois que je me suis l'heureux jensen
wayma désespérés parce que ça va pas
qu'est ce qu'il va faire j'avais acheté
une écharpe et parce qu'il la manie
effet racheté une écharpe va acheter une
écharpe
comme si les chars pas les cours
consolident besoin d'abord donc le
besoin d'amour débat serait d'une
écharpe
non alors moi c'est l'ex montre la manip
gel avaient d'un commerçant envers une
jeune femme qui est qui qui est perdu
est fragile notre cellule responsable le
texte montre une jeune femme qui perd
pied qui ne lit pas qui ne se cultive
pas et qui a besoin qu'on lui dise en
permanence qu'on lève qui n'a pas
beaucoup d'intérêt qui tombe sur ce
schalke pas très beau pas très séduisant
qui est dit n'est qu'il aime tellement
et 6 à comparer la façon dont charles m
avec ses petits moyens et dont emma m
avec ses grands moyens et bien permettez
moi de vous dire que pour moi en tant
que lecteur indépendant charles à sa
manière il m il se tait mais pourquoi
flobarts at il dit alors madame bovary
c'est moi je ne sais pas parce que eux
c'est des génies qui à une époque on
écrit il fait des femmes des personnages
importants
à une époque où la femme n'avait
poussons pas d'autres existences que
d'être une mère une mère maîtresse de
mer mer mais les enfants maîtresse de
maison ou sinon ils allaient dans l'est
dans l'est
et les soirées disons les maisons de
passes entre hommes pour discuter et ses
génies qui sont très modernes pour ça
que j'aime pas quand audi est classique
jo beaucoup plus modernes ont fait des
femmes des personnages complexes profond
fort autour de quel toute l'histoire
s'organise homme ou femme les
personnages qui vous plaît sont ceux qui
aime éperdument qui s'engagent et moi
j'aime le père goriot qui lui ce fait
abandonné par ses filles pour le coup
c'est un lieu d'entraînement
oui c'est ça il leur sacrifie tout ce
père goriot je crois que balzac et écrit
le père goriot 40 jours enfin c'est
quelque chose de fascinant
il n'y a pas un livre qui parle mieux de
l'amour d'un père pour sa fille comme je
suis perdue d'une fille de 6 ans giulia
cc c'est bouleversant le super goriot et
essaye de les protéger contre elle est
un personnage x exceptionnel vous qui
aimez les personnages amoureux qu'est ce
que vous pensez du narrateur de la
recherche du temps perdu
si vous ne doit pas aimer halal à la
hauteur de l'amour que vous définissez 6
- ce qui me fascine but peut-être dû
être choquer les puristes c'est que pour
moi
à l'ombre des jeunes filles en fleurs ou
guéris paie donc marcel proust d'un côté
tolstoï de l'autre c'est la même épopée
sauf que tolstoï c'est une épopée qui
traverse l'europe
proust c'est une épopée qui traversé son
cerveau ciné pop est pour vous la
recherche du temps perdu dans les jeux à
l'ombre des jeunes filles en fleur donc
c'est à dire quand il est dans la
chambre d'hôtel et qu'il observe la
première fois non m'sieur fillon
albertine il est bruyant dans leurs
filets il est à cabourg et quand ils
regardent le ruban dans les cheveux des
jeunes filles mais c'est les fanions des
armées russes
et françaises qui se font face c'est la
même épopée c'est la même intensité et
moi ce qui me fascine c'est la capacité
de proust de narrer la venturi mobile
parce que c'est une aventure chaque
dîner chez les verdurin devient une
bataille extravagantes et j'aime cette
capacité d'imagination
il se passe rien et vous êtes suffoquer
à l'idée de ce qui va arriver mais pour
moi thomas mann la montagne magique
comment s'appelle le héros en ce cas
ressortent peut-être vous vous souvenez
vous il va dans un sanatorium
il ne se passe absolument rien et
pendant 1000 pages on est haletant à
l'idée de savoir comment peut-être tout
souvenez-vous de cette scène sur le
balcon
il va plier la couverture en fourrure
qu'on donne à tous ceux qui souffrent
d'une infection poitrinaire et c'est ça
le roman le roman pour être épique n'a
pas besoin de cris et de fureur n'a pas
besoin de grands espaces
ça peut être une chambre où il est seul
avec sa mère l'a la dame qui s'occupe
d'eux et où il rêve l'esprit de proust
ça devrait agiter là dedans qu'est ce
qui fait que c'est une épopée c'est la
façon dont il l'écrit où c'est le fait
que vous puissiez vous identifier à ce
qui est décrit au jeu je me suis moi je
suis fascinée de la capacité raconter
des histoires leurs histoires leurs
tourments
tout devient prétexte à l'épopée je suis
proust comme suit le soleil quand je
reconnais que c'est osé la comparaison
mais en tout cas moi en tant que lecteur
c'est comme ça que je vois alors vous
dites que vous lisez beaucoup de romans
vous préférez les romans aux essais il
ya un auteur que vous avez rapidement
cité qui est à la fois philosophe et
romancier c'est albert camus avait cité
la correspondance magnifique avec
maria casarès qui effectivement vient
d'être publié la carte postale qui lui
écrit camus est autant l'auteur de la
peste que de noces par exemple qui est
un plex un recueil de très courts textes
je les lui apporter philosophique pas à
qui et les noces à tipaza notamment
qui est absolument bouleversant où on
est dans un type de récit qui l'a
complètement différents mais qui vous
parle aussi bon d'abord le rapport de
cabu à la nature on est vraiment très
proche de la narration à la proust parce
que il se passe rien or tipasa qu'est-ce
qui se passe le sentiment d'un homme par
rapport à la nature les odeurs le vent
mais moi ce qui m'intéresse dans camus
ce qui m'a toujours bouleversée c'est
que peut-être le thème le plus récurrent
de la littérature est celui qui fait du
naïf dû déranger du différent celui qui
touche la vérité au plus près l'étranger
vous pensez à l'étranger du cannet peut
dire que il pas normal au sens
l'étranger qui est qui et moquée fustigé
isolé par ce parce qu'ils ont la cellule
de ne pas avoir pleuré à l'enterrement
de sa propre main oui mais l'étranger il
me fait penser à l'idiot t2 à skis il me
fait penser à hans car thorpe qui lui
aussi un peu dérangé il me fait penser à
ford est le beau frère d'andré y ait
dans la grille est dressé la même chose
bayer il et il est très dérangé le beau
frère il est gênant tellement dérangé
mais quand il faut ressusciter les
enfants c'est lui qu'on va chercher et
et j'aime cette écriture qui fait du
différent celui qui tutoie la vérité
l'idiot n'a rien d'un idiot tout ce
qu'il dit est proche de la vérité
dans l'étranger c'est cela et puis moi
j'aime chez camus tout ce qui est
l'afrique du nord longtemps j'ai
j'aurais aimé naître en afrique du nord
ccc ville blanche écrasée de soleil les
plages d'alger rêver de de réussir à
paris c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
me touche et dans la peste et dans
l'enfermement je crois que ça se passe à
oran à la peste with le roman il ya sept
vies en afrique du nord
parce que curieusement alors que mon
père et hongrois plus ça va plus je me
sens méditerranéen et je pense que la
culture méditerranéenne l est tout
autant au sud de la méditerranée connor
la méditerranée
camus est autant du côté de l'amour que
d'une forme de jouissance de la nature
justement bien sûr pas du côté de
l'amour il l'est dans sa vie privée dans
sa correspondance parce que si on voit
ça si on voit sa correspondance c'est
d'ailleurs assez fascinant la
correspondance avec maria casarès oms
qui vient de sortir là ils sont restés
jusqu'à une dizaine d'années au sens de
48 à à 60 ans les amarres une dizaine
d'années ils ont été très séparés parce
qu'elle était une actrice je me souviens
j'ai été mariée voilà mais ils ont écrit
des centaines de lettres qui en disent
beaucoup celle où je pense que la
correspondance est plus importante
parfois qu'une partie de l'offre et mon
dieu comme c'est triste
notre tradition des emails maintenant
parce que qu'est-ce qui va rester mon
dieu vous aimeriez écrire des lettres
encore être ben j'aime recevoir sous un
délais très facile a dit non non non
alors savoir non non je parle d'un four
suis marié ma femme mais si vous voulez
qu est-ce qui va rester de nos texto
qu'est ce qui va rester de nos emails ou
le moindre email est donné en copie à 70
personnes sas archives un e-mail on peut
l'imprimer
quand vous pensez
camus c'est quand même pas le moyen-age
on est plein xxème siècle il ya 12 cents
pages de correspondance magnifique avec
son amoureuse
c'est ça la civilisation c'est ça la
modernité et tout ce qu'on nous présente
comme de la modernité c'est à dire le
truc en toc jetables consommables
recyclables partir j'ai rien contre ce
qui est recyclable gpoms me met mal à
qui que ce soit mais en vain qu'est-ce
qui vaut une lettre où maria casarès
comme camus rentre épuisé de journée et
avant de se coucher où elles apprennent
théâtral écrit tu sais je suis fatigué
mais je voulais écrire je voulais
décrire je voulais te dire ce que je
pensais qu'elle est l'écrivain
aujourd'hui qui va faire ça mais
justement parmi les écrivains
contemporains parce que nous n'avons
parlé il écrivains du 19e début moitié
du 20e siècle
est ce qu'il y avait un livre que vous
avez lu récemment de littérature
peut-être même étrangères qui retiendra
votre attention c'est moi chez quelle
j'ai un écrivain un jeune enfin je crois
qu'il ya une cinquantaine d'années je
n'ai jamais rencontré je ne connais pas
américain david vann vais à 2 n que
j'avais lu ya sept ou huit ans supplante
island qui trie stupéfiants et qui a
sorti il ya quelques mois à coire et
l'aquarium qui est un livre qui vous
suffoque c'est une histoire
extraordinaire
décidément je m'aperçois que j'aime
l'hérault féminin d'une femme abandonnée
qui élève seule sa fille je veux pas
raconter l'histoire est racontée pas
tout mais c'est vrai que et il va
arriver une histoire extraordinaire qui
est bouleversante et ce david vann et
quelqu'un dans la littérature
contemporaine qui m'impressionnait
énormément et vous avez amené d'ailleurs
ben vous m'aviez exemple d'aquarium je
vous ai demandé d'apporter les l'isthme
ces momies compté pour vous faire de ce
fait je vois qu'ils sont immaculés on
dirait qu'ils ont à peine été touché à
nancy si bien sûr mais david vann si
extraordinaire et comme vous me donniez
l'autorisation d'avoir quelques livres
mais oui dites nous quelles sont vos
livres
un auteur dont on parle pratiquement pas
ouais et qui est exceptionnel dit joseph
kessel
joseph kessel c'est dans la lignée
d'hemingway de romain gary
les cavaliers c'est l'histoire celui là
c'est l'histoire de au fond des
relations d'un d'un fils est son père il
veut épater son père ça ce passe temps
est-ce que c'est hadji qui ce temps est
ce que c'est
l'ouzbékistan est ce que c'est le
kazakhstan lisez les cavaliers vous ne
serez pas déçus celle aventures du
bronze c'est merveilleux vous prenez
grand symbole et vous n'écrivez pas sur
les livrets a que gelée stabilo boss de
temps en temps les stabilos beauce et
oui quand il ya quelque chose qui me
plaît parce que quand je vais reprend
après je lui ouvre et puis à quelque
chose euh je ne sais pas pourquoi je
stabilise telle phrase pas forcément un
plus belle mais parce que elle me touche
je puis j'ai amené les cerfs-volants
romain gary c'est jean marie roy
je n'avais pas lu j'avais le
pratiquement tous gary mais je n'avais
pas lu les cerfs-volants de l'écrivain
contemporain jean marie roy avec
jean-marie vous étiez en compte mais
derrière soi même excellent écrivain
quelques qui m'a dit tu devrais lire les
cerfs-volants et les cerfs-volants c'est
bouleversant
parce que c'est le dernier livre de
romain gary c'est une magnifique
histoire d'amour entre une petite
polonaise un petit français
bouleversé par la guerre c'est
magnifique c'est vraiment touchant et ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est de penser
quand romain gary écrivait ce livre
c'était le dernier parce qu'il n'allait
suicidé quelques semaines en 1980 mais
oui je crois même 84 enfin pour moi au
début des années 80 et comment peut-on
écrire peut-être plaidoyer sur l'amour
et avoir l'idée de se suicider et la
sacem est délabré c'est quelque chose
qui me touche c'est quelque chose pour
moi c'est très important
il a dédicacé les cerfs-volants à la
mémoire
alors ça ça me touche énormément parce
que on dédicace à l'avenir en général
mais lui il fait à la mémoire et 110
tellement long sur l'état d'esprit de
celui qui avait déjà eu 2 me prie je
crois que ces concours ville de nîmes et
émile agen bien emile ajar
et puis romain gary et il fait le
dernier livre et le dédicace à la
mémoire je n'avais jamais vu ça pour moi
vous voyez ça c'est quelque chose qui me
touche mais qu'est ce qu'on voulait
quand j'étais prêt sinon on aurait pu
que j'ai parlé de ça pour rien fou ce
type là et pourquoi pas mais bon c'est
pas parce qu'on n'attendait pas de match
face à mais pour moi c'est ça qui me
touche c'est ça qui me qui me plaît
c'est ça qui me je pourrais même dire
qui d'une certaine façon qui me
bouleverse
et puis marguerite duras quand même une
écrivaine
ben oui c'est tellement extraordinaire
un barrage contre le pacifique une femme
aussi très forte et les trois
enseignantes
et puis elle se dit on va gagner de
l'argent doc est hélas une parcelle dans
ce qu'on appelle la qu'aucun chine et on
va cultiver du riz
je crois qu'elle a deux filles une qui
est un peu curieuse c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs marguerite
duras et même un fils et puis il faut un
barrage contre le pacifique parce que
naturellement pour cultiver du riz faut
de l'eau mais pas de l'eau salée mais à
l'écran par tous et les crabes
détruisent l'a dit et c'est quelque
chose de d'extraordinaire de simplicité
on sent en lisant la moiteur du climat
aux coquins chine vous êtes attentif le
rallumage marguerite duras qui avait
discuté avec avec françois mitterrand
bien sûr
mais pourquoi moi vous savez les
opinions politiques des écrivains
non mais c'est pour montrer qu'on peut
être homme politique et assumer une un
rapport au texte à la littérature sans
que ça nuise à l'exercice du pouvoir
vont heureusement
heureusement marguerite duras ai jamais
revus je le conseille tout ce qu'ils
n'ont pas vu les je crois que a été
réédité une dizaine d'entretiens de
pivot avec des grands auteurs nabokov
lolita pour moi d'ailleurs dans lolita
la victime c'est le le le gendre et pas
lolita pas y aurait beaucoup à dire là
dessus
le film de kubrick aussi d'avis qui a
repris lolita mais qui a été remis au
goût du jour par des polémiques
actuelles justement sur la question de
la majorité de l'âge sexuelle de l'année
c'est la différence entre le cinéma
parce que dans nabokov lolita est plus
jeune que d'un kubrick
si vous souvenez de ce film tout à fait
extraordinaire qui est en noir et blanc
lolita au fond le dit à la fin le seul
que j'ai vraiment aimé ses suites ils
voulaient ma mère prostituée et pas
celui qu'elle perde son enfant alors je
pense que dans nabokov et l'été et les
ailes étaient plus jeunes mais ce qu'il
trouve aujourd'hui de voir que la
littérature ce livre peut poser problème
en tout cas si on dissocie pas la
littérature d'à côté de la société de
l'autre parce que se posent problème
acquis aux petits esprits gants comme ça
la littérature c'est la littérature
c'est de mettre de la liberté et vous
comprenez moi j'ose donner mon opinion
sur balzac sur flaubert je n'ai aucune
compétence pour ça mais je la donne avec
ma sincérité de lecteurs
je pense que le lecteur est aussi
propriétaire de l'oeuvre et je pense que
c'est intéressant de lire en donnant de
la vie la chair aux personnages pas de
le lire savoir à quelle époque c'était
qu'est ce qu'il a voulu du derrière noms
commencent à me parle
qu'est ce que toi tu as ressenti je
pense que
ça qu'on devrait apprendre à nos enfants
pas ce que balzac flaubert zola que
j'adore tout maupassant tous les génies
dont on a parlé ont voulu dire mais toi
mon petit qu'as tu ressenti en lisant ça
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est pas
du tout je ne veux pas dire que flaubert
n'était pas intéressant mais toi un
siècle et demi après ça fait écho à quoi
et on devrait bien me dire à nos enfants
bras vous avez lu ce chef-d'oeuvre aux
adolescents aux jeunes qu'est ce que
vous en pensez plutôt qu'essayer de
reconstruire ce qu est l état d'esprit
ça c'est pour les érudits mais à l'école
c'est beaucoup mieux et on aurait des
milliers d'interprétation balzac et à ce
moment-là balzac deviendrait une oeuvre
vivante comme elle le mérite de l'être
et non pas savoir s'il écrivait avec sa
robe de cachemire à quelle heure il
écrivait si le crime et de blues il en
reste un et puis bon mais incontournable
houellebecq michel houellebecq
incontournable
pourquoi si c'est var elle garde la
france a ordonné dans son constat et
c'est un écrivain qui me touche
énormément d'une lucidité extrêmement
profond est absolument contraire à
l'apparence qu'il donne c'est à dire
qu'elle est sans d'abord quand on voit
les cantons à michel houellebecq au on
pense pas immédiatement à la lucidité à
la tranquillité et aucun absolue mais il
ya un côté un peu sagan dans sa manière
par les rangs du temps ils se moquent de
la forme et tout ce qu'il dit
passionnant et j'ai aimé soumission non
pas parce qu'il est branché avec
l'actualité mais parce qu'il a une
capacité à définir des personnages
extraordinaires et puis 7
grand poète peut-être plus grande
aujourd'hui soumission donc de michel
houellebecq nicolas sarkozy on va se
quitter avec une chanson figurez-vous
parce qu'on trouve aussi de la
littérature en chansons on s'est demandé
quelle chanson que vous ferez plaisir
d'entendre ce soir on a beaucoup parlé
littérature du 19e siècle début xxème
siècle un peu de contemporains une
chanson contemporaine dont voici les
premières notes de l'anah reconnaît tout
de suite
[Musique]
je veux mes yeux dans vos yeux je veux
ma voix dans votre oreille
je veux les mains fraîche du vent
[Musique]
je veux encore le mal d'aimer
le mage de tous ceux qui émerveille
je veux encore brûlé doucement
[Musique]
marché à deux pas du soleil
et je veux déranger les pierres
il changer le visage morzine je la
connais par coeur
elle me touche toujours autant à ton
fils teints et bornés parole sans carla
bruni gens faibles
vous allez croire que j'ai un peu
partisan mais pour moi c'est un très
grand auteur français et je suis
toujours assez bouleversé quand carla
écrit quand julien clerc composent une
un quart et un immense compositeur je
parle pas des chanteurs
naturellement les deux mais la rencontre
et exception et vraiment je vous m'avez
fait doublement plaisir plaisir en
invitant pour parler de certainement
très mal parlé mais j'espère que vous
avez compris pour moi c'était important
et est terminée par déranger les pierres
près compris mais là je crois que c'est
une chanson qu'elle a écrit en 2007
c'est vous qui savez oui je pense mais
je peux pas me trompe merci beaucoup à
nicolas sarkozy c'est moi donc une
longue vie à l'émission il je peux vous
dire que c'est un grand plaisir
d'autres appliquent ou plaisir partagé à
bientôt j'espère on se quitte avec
gignac là
son du printemps
[Musique]
grand soleil de satan
aux siennes
comme un mendiant
[Musique]
angers le visage
c'était livrez vous avec le concours du
centre national du livre